hello all just a quick announcement to
let you know that finally I have set up
a patreon for voices of the past my name
is David and I run voices of the past so
before do you think the channel does is
worthwhile if you think it's important
to hear the past through the words of
the people who actually lived it and of
course help preserve primary sources
please to head over to the patreon but
for now enjoy the video
[Music]
BRAC now's the son of King Sigurd ring
and his first wife I'll field his father
when an old man had fallen deeply in
love with Alf Sol the daughter of King
Alpha Strickland her brothers refused to
give her in marriage to so old a man and
when they were defeated in battle by
c-code ring they poisoned her rather
than she should become his wife the King
thereupon had her corpse carried on
board his ship which he steered out into
the open sea and then plunged his sword
into his heart
thus dying beside the body of his
beloved afsal Ragnar therefore although
only 15 years of age was now king he was
remarkable as well for his great beauty
as for the dauntless courage which he
always displayed when he went with his
followers on marauding expeditions to
foreign lands on one of these
expeditions he landed on the coast of
Norway and penetrated alone into the
heart of the land on gaining the summit
of a hill he threw himself on the soft
turf to rest and to enjoy the beautiful
landscape which spread itself out before
his view the green valley at his feet
the lake sparkling like diamonds in the
sunshine and the verdant meadows and
cornfields as he gazed on this fair
picture his mind was filled with the
idea that the wild and warlike life he
had hitherto that was after all far less
satisfactory than a life of peaceful
quiet happiness as he thus pondered he
suddenly became aware that two hostile
divisions of soldiers had entered the
valley presently their trumpets sounded
and they rode at one another Full Tilt
with their shields raised
his surprise was great to receive that
one of the divisions was led by a
beautiful woman who was mounted on a
milk-white charger and dressed in silver
armor while her lovely raven locks
escaping from under her helmet fell in
rich profusion over her neck and
shoulders
she wrote before her soldiers cheering
them on and fighting the enemy herself
with sword and spear many fell beneath
her strokes but the enemy being too
strong for her little man to resist they
were obliged to retreat not so the
heroic maiden captivity or death
threatened to be her doom yet still she
fought on with indomitable courage her
bright silver armor making her
conspicuous wherever the battle was
hottest Ragnar seeing that she stood in
sore need of help could no longer remain
an inactive spectator of the scene but
seizing his sword he hastened to her
side and fought desperately against the
enemy his sword made such havoc amongst
the foe and such numbers of their best
warriors were slain that at length those
who were left were obliged to seek
safety in flight as soon as the battle
was over Ragnar straightaway withdrew to
his ship there he learned that the name
of the soldier maid was a lagertha that
she ruled the surrounding country and
dwelt in a beautiful place in the midst
of her possessions the following day he
repaired
Lizza and was received by lagertha with
much joy and gratitude has a friend and
deliverer Ragnar remained a guest at the
palace for three days after which time
as he loved lagertha dearly he besought
her to become his wife
to which she joyfully consented Ragnar
and lagertha lived very happily together
for some time she was an excellent wife
to him but she refused to leave her own
country for his No
which she resigned to him her rights as
sovereign Ragnar past three peaceful
years at her side but at last the
warlike spirit woke again within him and
when he heard that the Danish Islands
had rebelled against his rule and became
independent he parted from his wife who
could not bring herself to leave her
peaceful home for a strange country and
set out for his own Kingdom alone in a
very little while he succeeded in
putting down the rebels and proceeded to
his palace at Halle drew covered with
glory one day a stranger at his court
showed him in a magic mirror a virgin of
wonderful beauty the king was so
enchanted at the sight of her that he
could hardly take his eyes from her face
and declared that the man who could call
such a treasure his own must be the
happiest being on earth yes indeed
replied the stranger now say us truly
for this noble maid is not only famous
for her beauty but also for her wisdom
and goodness her father Herod of east
Scotland asks her advice on all
occasions and if he follows it his
enterprises are always successful now
however both he and his daughter are in
great distress some time ago two of his
warriors presented him with a Griffin's
egg which was part of the plunder which
they had brought home with them from a
foreign land it was hatched at the
King's orders by a swan and a curious
little winged serpent came out of it he
gave that little creature to his
daughter who put it in a golden cage and
fed it with her own hands
it grew however so quickly that it was
soon too large for the cage and even for
the room and now it surrounds the whole
house in which the princess lives
the monster is still submissive to her
but he guards her with a jealous eye
nor will he allow her to leave the house
or receive food from anyone but the man
who daily brings him an ox for his meals
no one dares attempt to touch him for
his eyes are like flaming fire his
breath his deadly poison and with his
tail he can break the strongest oak tree
as easily as if it were a reed the king
therefore in order to rid himself of
this curse has promised the hand of his
daughter to whom ever shall succeed in
slaying the monster before Ragnar had
heard the completion of this tale he had
determined to set out on the adventure
himself he lost no time in procuring a
garment of thick wool and ox-hide which
he steeped in tar for he knew that
through such a garment neither poison no
venom could penetrate accompanied by
many warlike companions he set out for
East goth lend and landed on the coast
not far from the king's castle wrapped
in his tarred garment and armed with a
mighty spear he started for the
princess's abode there surrounding the
house with his huge body he beheld the
monster apparently
asleep he attempted several times to
stab him but in vain his spear could not
pierce the scales of the serpent which
were hard and smooth as steel presently
the monster raised its huge body and
tried to seize Ragnar in its jaws
hissing meanwhile with rage and spitting
its deadly venom at him but as it thus
coiled itself about Ragnar perceived an
exposed spot under its throat where the
scales appeared to be soft and at this
spot he aimed his spear with all the
strength he could muster for a few
moments the creature writhed and turned
in agony so that the house was shaken to
its foundation and then suddenly the
great monster sank to the ground
dead the princess awakened by the noise
stepped to the window and beheld the
victor clothed in his rude garments but
before she had time to look upon him
more closely he withdrew himself from
her gaze Herod as soon as he received
news of the event ordered a proclamation
to be made to the effect that the people
should meet together in an assembly in
order to decide whom the prize should be
awarded to on the appointed day Ragnar
took his place in the Assembly clothed
in his tarred garments at the command of
the King to heralds carried about among
the men the point of the spear which had
been taken from the Serpent's body in
order to discover who among them
possessed the shaft to which it fitted
when Ragnar produced the same and fitted
the point of the sphere onto it the king
taking him to be a poor man exclaimed in
astonishment huh
thou leather garments and who taught
thee that clever thrust comes Lao from
the Bahama country that thou has such an
odour of pitch and tar about thee these
words Ragnar dropped his disguise and
stood in his royal attire before the
assembled people rakhna Ragnar it is the
king himself cried a multitude of voices
and Herod stepping down from his throne
embraced him saying thou shalt in future
be called leather
garments in remembrance of thy valour
and I will give thee the hand of my
daughter in marriage the King kept his
word and the princess thora joyfully
consented to become the wife of her
brave deliverer nor had she ever any
cause to regret her choice for her
husband was so devoted to her that he
even gave up his marauding expeditions
in order to remain at her side the
happiness was augmented by the birth of
two sons Eric and
aDNA but fate suffers no perfect
happiness to be on earth and ere long
thora died in the arms of her
disconsolate Lord and now peace and
happiness fled from the palace and
sorrow and mourning reigned in their
stead for Ragna was inconsolable for the
loss of his wife at length one of the
noblest of his warriors stepped before
him and represented to him how it was
that he was still young and in the prime
of his life and it was a sin for him to
waste his best years in mourning for his
departed Queen his words roused to the
sleeping ardor of the king and soon he
was once more tossing in his ship on the
billowy ocean where amidst dangers and
diverse adventures he strove to forget
his great sorrow
one day landing on the coast of Norway
he sent his servants inland to prepare
food and bake bread after wandering
about they came to a lowly peasants Hut
and on entering they found within it
across hideous old woman sitting
cowering over the fire they asked her to
help them make the bread but she excused
herself on account of her great age just
then a young peasant girl entered the
cottage and the men on seeing her stared
at her with open mouths and could not
find words to address her for they had
never before seen so exquisitely lovely
a woman yes yes that is my daughter
croaked the old hag see cracker these
men would make bread and do not know how
without making any reply the girl set
about preparing the dough herself and
when she had put the loaves into the
oven she directed the mental watched
them as she had other work
to do but the man only had eyes for the
beautiful girl who with wonderful
adroitness went about the cottage
cleaning and putting everything to
rights in consequence of their
negligence some of the loaves were burnt
and when they returned on board the ship
they were scolded and punished for their
carelessness they declared however that
the king himself would have been guilty
of the same negligence had he
endeavoured to watch the bread in the
presence of such a beautiful maid their
words aroused the curiosity of the king
and he gave orders that this wonderful
maiden should be brought before him on
board his vessel on the following
morning she was to come unattended and
yet not alone naked and he had closed
fasting and yet for this strange command
was given to Clara who accordingly
appeared before the king the next day
with a fisherman's net wrapped in fools
about her and accompanied by shepherd's
dog she taken some of the juice of a
leek so that she was neither fasting nor
full in just this way she obeyed the
command of the king to the letter Ragnar
was much impressed by her wisdom but
still more so by her wonderful beauty
her fair silken locks and blue eyes in
which the light of heaven was reflected
he straightaway offered to make her his
queen but she having no great faith in
the constancy of man desired him to
complete his voyage and then if he
should still be of the same mind to
return to Norway and repeat his offer
the king submitted to the will of the
peasant girl and departed his devotion
to her however was unchangeable and
immediately on his return from his
voyage he fetched her from her peasant
home and took her to his palace at Halle
drew as his bride and their celebrated
his marriage feast
[Music]
cracker bore her husband four sons the
eldest of whom named Eva who's very
handsome and had strong broad shoulders
but his lower limbs were so weak that he
always had to be carried about the other
three sons were strong healthy youths
who awaited impatiently the time when
they like their half-brothers Eric and
agna should be permitted to go on
distant voyages and return with rich
plunder from foreign lands meanwhile the
people began to murmur and complain that
the peasant girl had been set upon the
throne and the courtiers who were as
dissatisfied as the people repeated
these murmurings to the king ragnar
greatly displeased that these complaints
set out force with the odd to pay a
visit to his friend King eistein he was
cordially welcomed at the court and the
daughter of the mighty King waited upon
him herself and filled his goblet with
sparkling wine and sat beside him at the
board Ragnar was enchanted as well by
her beauty as by her conversation and
when the courtiers pointed out to him
the advantage of an alliance with the
princess he allowed himself to be
persuaded and asked for the Kings
consent to his marriage with his
daughter this the King granted and it
was arranged that as soon as their
betrothal had been solemnized Ragnar
should return home and under some excuse
divorce is peasant wife when he arrived
at his palace at her Ladera cracka came
out as usual with glad and smiling
countenance to welcome him home she
seemed not to notice his cold greeting
but did her utmost to provide him with
every possible comfort after his journey
and asked if he had brought any news on
his replying surly that he had none to
give she informed him that she had heard
a strange report about his best friend
that he had wished to divorce his
rightful spouse in order to marry a
king's daughter and the
petrosal had already been solemnized
what nave informed thee of that cried
Ragnar angrily my chattering Magpies she
quietly replied thou knowest them for
they were present at king ice teens
court during thy stay there full of
anxiety I sent them after thee and they
brought me a faithful report of thy
doings if thou dost indeed intend to
carry out thy plan I will return to the
peasant folk whom people believed to be
my parents they murdered my foster
father
Jaime R and now thou wilt destroy the
happiness of my life before you do
anything rash listen to me and I will
reveal to thee a secret
know then that my name is not cracker
but a slob for I am the daughter of King
Sigurd the Dragon Slayer who ranks us
high over all the kings of the north as
the son ranks above the stars
my mother was bring Hilde when my father
was Fowley and secretly murdered by his
brothers-in-law ganaron hagen the good
high mare for fear of the murderers bore
me away in a harp from the unhappy land
and after wandering about for a long
time came to the peasants hut in which
you found me the two inhabitants of the
hut thinking the harp contained great
treasures murdered my faithful protector
in his sleep by night but did not dare
to make away with the child which they
discovered in the place of the gold they
had expected to find
thus I grew up with them in the cottage
they allowed me to keep my mother's
wedding ring together with her picture
and the letter which she wrote before
her death here is the proof of my story
graça continued producing the letter and
the ring and yet another token has Odin
revealed to me it shall be made manifest
when our unborn babe shall behold the
light of the world for in his eye he
shall have a mark like a tiny serpent as
she ceased speaking she laid aside her
royal jewels and turned to depart but
Ragnar who stood shamefaced and abashed
before the noble woman whose royal
descent he now recognized besought her
to stay she loved him so dearly that she
could not withstand his entreaties but
remained with him and in due time
presented him with a little son who bore
on him the prophesized mark of
distinction and was therefore called
Sigurd the serpent eyed
meanwhile Eric and Agnetha the sons of
Ragnar's first wife thora had made the
name famous by their warlike deeds they
had opportunity of displaying their
valor in the war which now broke out
with King eistein who was enraged at a
Ragnar's rejection of his daughter Eric
and agna landed on the Swedish coast but
they both fell in the battle which
ensued feist teens host was too strong
for them and their ranks were thrown
into confusion by the enchanted bull
which the King had ordered to be driven
amongst them when the news of their
defeat and death reached Ragnar skort
his third son IVA forthwith set out to
avenge his brother's untimely end
no sooner was the battle opened however
that the huge Enchanted Bull rushed
bellowing as before amongst the soldiers
causing terror and confusion in the
ranks Ivar therefore lost no time in
seizing his mighty bow and arrow and
taking aim of the monster he pissed it
through the heart so that it fell dead
on the field after this the battle was
easily won eistein himself being struck
down while attempting to fly for his
life Ragnar Suns engaged in many other
Wars and piratical expeditions their
combined forces conquered the rich town
of wilfers Berg after which they marched
to Luna in air Korea they found it
strongly garrisoned and therefore sent
messengers into the town to say that
they came with peaceful intentions
merely to buy victuals that their
captain Hastings who was sick to death
wish to be baptized and received into
the Christian Church delighted with this
news the inhabitants immediately opened
communication with the strangers and the
holy ceremony of baptism was performed
over the sick man the governor of the
town standing sponsor a few days later
an emissary was sent to inform the
inhabitants that Hastings was dead and
that his dying wish had been that his
corpse might be allowed a resting place
in the Christian Church to which he had
bequeathed his riches
with the desire that the priests should
annually say three masses for his soul
the messenger ended by declaring that if
this was allowed to take place it was
his belief that the whole army who
intended unarmed to accompany the body
of their leader to the grave would
consent to be baptized the request was
granted on the day of the funeral the
church was so crowded by the clergy
nobles and citizens of the town that
there was hardly any room left for the
Northman the requiem was solemnly
chanted the blessing was spoken and the
body of the departed soldier was just
about to be lowered into the grave when
the lid of the bier sprang open the dead
man rose up in his shroud with a drawn
sword in his hand with which he at once
slew all who came within his reach the
rest of the soldiers likewise drew forth
their arms which they had kept concealed
beneath their garments and massacred
without mercy the unarmed people who
filled the church they then rushed out
into the streets plundering and
murdering wherever they went and setting
the town on fire this was the strategy
by which means the north men possessed
themselves of the town of Luna while his
sons were engaged in these warlike
expeditions King Ragnar himself was not
idle he determined on an invasion of
Britain
in order to force King Ella to pay him
tribute for this purpose he had two new
ships built large enough to carry a
great number of soldiers and with these
he landed on the British coast he
devastated the country in a terrible
manner and engaged in many bloody
battles but he never received any wound
for a slog had woven him a magic garment
through which neither shot nor sword
could penetrate
one day ships were driven by a storm
into a Northumbrian Bay where they
struck upon a rock and founded he
however with many of his men and some
arms succeeded in gaining the shore here
they soon encountered others forces but
the brave soldier nothing daunted did
not hesitate a moment with his handful
of followers to commence the attack he
fought without flinching in the hottest
part of the battle but as his brave
soldiers fell around him he was at
length surrounded by the enemy and taken
prisoner no one recognized him and as he
refused to answer any of the questions
put to him King Ella in anger ordered
him to be thrown into a dungeon full of
serpents at first a slugs magic garment
protected him from any hurt but the
guards when they perceived this deprived
him of it and he soon after succumbed to
their venomous stings
thus died brave King Ragnar like a hero
as he was uttering neither cry no
complaint under his slow torture but
singing in rich clear tones a dirge of
the Northland
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]